[Music]
so let's have a look at docker and this
is basically the docker container
management tool so what is it it's
basically it's a container platform it
enables you to create containers run
images and things like that and it's
basically each container runs typically
one application is the idea a container
can run multiple applications that's
that he's allowed but the kind of
philosophy behind it suggests that every
container should contain a single
application and have a very very minimum
implementation so that there's no
interference between different
applications so docker container can say
serve a base line X operating system
which is basically all the tools and
utilities needed to operate a a Linux
environment so you will have all the
tools like LS and PS and and the ones
that you're going to need but what you
won't have or any of the boot mechanisms
processes or scripts because there isn't
a boot mechanism and anything else
that's required any packages that are
required to work to operate and so it's
very it's a good jail you can't get out
of it we don't know of anybody that has
got out of one yet it might be possible
and what we do is you start off with an
image which is just basically a big file
and or maybe a not too big file and then
the image becomes the runnable container
and so outside you've got two Dockers
you have many containers you got the
operating system and kernel and anything
else docker is just an application that
runs on your operating system and
enables you to run containers seamlessly
as standalone applications which are
completely isolated from anything else
so docker is traditionally Linux and the
it was for a long time it was only
supported on Linux and until fairly
recently because it needs the
functionality from certain versions of
the kernel which is anyone after the the
technology was enabled it requires a
64-bit installation
at least at least a 3/10 Linux kernel
and it'll run on most favors of Linux
not necessarily easily on all of them
for the fame for the popular ones such
as Debian and CentOS and under bun -
it's pretty easy to get it running
though there are some issues with the
Centaurs version I found some problems
and you can get it as an RPM on a PT
package and just install it or you can
download from docker directly as a
binary version for some versions of Unix
Linux you need to do that use a binary
version if you go to the docker website
it'll tell you what you need to do for
your particular flavor of Linux docker
for OSX came out fairly recently it was
earlier this year it now runs natively
on OSX and which is good and you just
get a GED mg package which you just
install it it's built on herb and the
hypervisor technology it only works on
fairly recent Macs
so it's got to be at least a a Mac 2010
because it needs the support for the the
memory management within the CPU and
earlier Mac's didn't have sufficiently
late versions of the process that was
supported this technology it requires a
fairly recent version of OS X 10 to 3 at
least 4 gigs of ram because it does use
up some memory there is a problem with
them the OS X version which was very
frustrating when I was working on this
material there has been a problem that
Apple and the docker people I've got an
issue communicating about networking so
when you reinstall docker on OS X which
is what I'm actually running it on you
cant do proper networking because docker
is not capable of creating the right
network device to be able to communicate
externally it's not the end of the world
you can still use docker on OS X but you
can't do certain things we've got
container spread over multiple hosts
there's also a version for Windows it
only works on the very latest versions
of Windows 10 and though they said they
might support earlier ones it also
requires a package called hyper-v which
is a virtualization package to work and
it it does the things and virtualizes
the environment so that you can run
effectively Linux stuff on Windows so it
has to effectively look like a a Linux
kernel in some respects VirtualBox for
virtual machines cannot be run at the
same time as darker because the hyper-v
package in the VirtualBox pack M
application are incompatible with each
other they can't work together so if
your OS is not supported the stinkle
darker toolbox and docker toolbox is
what you had to use on OS X and Windows
before the first part of this year when
it was finally released what it is it's
a virtual machine its uses VirtualBox
and it's completely packaged a virtual
machine running a Linux operating system
which has got darker installed on it and
so you just run that as a normal virtual
machine on your operating system and
then you've got darker which can then
run other applications docker engine is
the key part so docker has got a number
of components as will be seeing mainly
today but there was another section on
another aspect of docker in a later
lesson it client server you've got
basically a a background daemon process
which does all the work and it's got a
restful api this normally and by default
works over a a UNIX socket so it
requires the API the client program to
run on the same machine if you've got it
on this UNIX socket it is possible to
make it listen on a tcp/ip port and then
you can have remote clients to the
docker server this is one where area
where you can't work on OS X because if
the server's on on a OS X the client
can't connect to it from under the
machine but you can to go the other way
so the server ISA is the daka daemon and
what
does is it it manages the containers so
it can go and fetch them they can build
them it can run them and it can put them
somewhere else so that containers
themselves where are they stored well as
a number of places docker hub is a
repository set of repositories up on on
the cloud and that enables you to get
images of a vast number of things there
are docker images for all of the major
distributions of Linux and they've got
multiple versions of each of the
distributions of Linux they all cut down
it's also got many many applications so
if you want say a MySQL server there's a
container up on docker hub which has got
MySQL running on top of some flavor of
Linux and you can just pull it down and
run it and any other application which
is popular so if you want to a Jenkins
CI server a continuous integration
server you can just pull one down so you
don't have to configure your own and
these things are pretty neat actually
because what they they're configured in
such a way that if you specify certain
options when you run the image as a
container it was effectively configure
itself so as we'll see in the next
lesson if you pull the MySQL container
down you can firstly you can fire it up
in a way that it creates a database and
a user and then but you can also fire it
up in it when it's configured and it's
got an existing database in users they
could also think fire it up as a client
and access another container which is
the database server so they've done
quite a lot of work on making this stuff
really user friendly you can also have
private images you can create your own
images and in fact docker keeps its own
collection of images locally so doesn't
have to go fetch them all the time and
the other other places where you can get
images from other vendors so an images
are a template and say it's usually a
cut-down version of a line-ups operating
system and you just add applications to
the image and basically an image is a
template and then you provide as
of operations which builds on it so you
just say okay I want to add this install
this software I want to do this do this
do this and it basically has layers to
the container and and then you've got
your fill image which could then be run
they can have all sorts of things you
can run them start them stop them delete
them they're all good good safe stuff so
the images are built in layers each each
the file system it's a union file system
so what'll happen is if you go to docker
hub and Paul Sayer MySQL image you will
see it'll do a series of downloads
probably about maybe six to ten separate
downloads each of the downloads is a
separate layer on top of the container
does it support HTTP yes it does you
might need to do some configuration for
um configuring HTTP but yes he does one
thing we will be doing actually is
building a container which is an SSH
server so we can connect via SSH to it
so yeah it pulls the base image it pulls
the the layers and it does the Downloads
in parallel and then when they're all
there it just builds it'll together into
a continue into the base image and as a
single what looks like a single unit but
it's actually um layered and so if you
do a well one thing that's very powerful
is if you make a slight change it won't
have to write download everything or if
something slightly changes so to give an
example I was trying to build an image
and as inevitably I made some mistakes
in the configuration when I was trying
to build it and so when I fixed it made
two changes to my configuration and did
a rebuild it didn't have to go and fetch
the bit is all he'd got is it had cached
them effectively so that meant the
natural bandwidth and download that was
required was minimizing to only
downloaded the things that I'd added
that hadn't already been done which is
really neat so you have a an image and
you used the docker run command which
creates a container so basically the
image is read-only effectively and the
container is a copy of the
image which is it an actual container
running the file system so when you say
run it'll first of all look for local
copy if it doesn't find digital gonna
search for it and the containers created
from the image itself as effectively as
on a separate file system it adds a
write layer to the top of the file
system so that you can't make changes to
it
it also creates a network
to face and assigned to an IP address
the weight actually works is the docker
daemon acts as a gateway to a a private
internal network on your machine is an
internal subnet and the containers are
attached to that subnet we look at
networking in more detail later it's
actually quite powerful you can also
connect optionally the input output and
error streams so you can interact with
the container if you wish or you can run
into the background process so the
docket whenever it's run the docker
container just appears as a child
process so this shows the daemon process
here which started with certain options
and then in process one 410 was a
Chinese a child of docker which he's the
container running in his case a shell
which is one way of it who actually
starting containers are quite powerful
so to run an image it has to be on the
computer and so docker has its own
little collection of images which and if
he hasn't got one it'll either need to
be created locally or pulled from a
registry and the pool just simply does a
transfer of all the layers and puts them
together into a cache and then you run
them to get the container so this is the
example that they're shown there this is
we wanted to sent us every single
container usually has a colon latest
version you can specifically ask for a
version so you can say I want CentOS
version seven point something and it
will fetch you that particular version
of sent us and then you can run that ten
tainer
and what you do is for many of the
container will have some kind of default
program which he's configured into it
which will run so if we just run it as a
background process it'll fire up some
application which the container was
built to do whatever that might be
you can in the case of say a senders
want what any of the containers you can
specify a command so if you go docker
run CentOS color latest Who am I
it'll create a container from the image
and start it up and run the Who am I
program and it'll then exit and the same
were there any other command so you can
run a single command like this not
tremendously useful but it shows you the
principle typically you'll be running a
real epic
or quite often you'll run shell so that
you can interact within the container
itself and make changes to it so the way
to do this is to wait interactively
docker run - I keeps the standard input
stream open so you can use the keyboard
and - T allocates a 32d Y device which
means you can you can actually interact
with the tty drivers inside the
container and you normally go talk and
run - I T or - t I specify the image and
specify the path to a shell and that
will actually run that CentOS container
and give you a shell prompt so you'll
get the hash prompt as a root shell
incidentally the processes inside the
container your bash shell will be
processed number one in the side the
container because the process IDs are
mapped so process ID one in the
container will map to process ID
something else in the actual host
operating system you can do some
interrogation if you do a docker PS
it'll list all the running containers in
your machine and the container will give
it will be given a name by default the
name is quite comical but you can
specify an actual name you can also do
docker stats which shows you the
resource usage and you need to it
terminate that with a control see says
something to try playing around with so
it's very useful I always do this docker
run - IT - - name and then you give it a
sensible name because then you can use
that name to control the container so
that's the first ones running the
container you can stop it using docker
stop and you can remove it docker RM
deletes the container itself which you
probably want to do quite a lot at the
time because you just throw it away
we'll talk about files - external file
systems and what happens cuz that when
the container is destroyed everything
that goes with it
goes as well unless you've attached some
external storage which we'll look at you
can also attach to a running container
and so for example if you're running one
container interactively on the first one
if you go to a second terminal and go
docker attached CentOS it'll attach your
terminal to it but you actually got the
same session so if one terminal if you
type into it in one terminal you'll see
the output in both because it's
effectively both attached to the same
container and there's this magic
keystroke control P control queue to
detach from the container leaving it
running so that means you can
effectively walk away from the cooler
detach yourself from the container and
then reattach yourself later on if you
wish to the stock a stop for terminating
containers you can opportunity given its
a time interval and say main process
process ID one which is not in it it's
the the main application started in the
container gets a term signal and then
after the interval gets a kill signal to
make sure it goes away you can oppose a
container as well that basically puts
all of the processes in the container to
sleep it doesn't use the standard UNIX
six stop sig term mechanism because of
the process fillers might be able to see
them it uses a a control group freeze
mechanism which basically all the
processes in the C group and it's child
processes child groups are put to sleep
without the processes knowing about it
and then you can resume them if you wish
you with the unpause when a container
stops or terminates it actually doesn't
go away it just goes into a stop state
if you do PS docker PS minus a it'll
show you all of the containers including
the stopped at once which is very useful
and you can restart it by doing a docker
start and you've got the option of
adding the connecting the input and
output streams to it
removing containers you just do Stucker
RM CentOS in that case if the containers
running it will refuse to do it unless
you add the minus F switch to force it
to stop PS minus a queue command shows
just the container IDs so that command
at the bottom docker RM dollar docker PS
minus a cue he effectively deletes all
the containers on the current machine
you can run them in the background mark
using the minus D for daemon switch or
detach switch and you can send signals
to the container as well using the
docker kill command
so that's the idea of docker containers
now Randy will demonstrate how to use
the Java command to find and run docker
containers
welcome to DevOps lesson 2 lab number 1
docker
let's switch to our terminal and the
first thing we want to do is to make
sure that we're running the latest
version of docker so we can get that
information by saying docker - - version
and there we see it's release one dot
12.3 which is just fine for us next we
want to get an image that we can run as
a container there is a public registry
that's available by default and I happen
to know that there is a Linux
distribution that we can use called
alpine so we're gonna pull that image
down from the registry and load it on
our machine and a local cache there we
go
it's pulled down now we can run docker
images to see what's on our computer and
there we see that we have the latest
version of Alpine and here is its image
ID the image ID is a hash of the
contents of the image and you can tell
if an image is the same image as another
one on your computer by comparing the
image IDs if that's the same then you
know you have the same image that
becomes significant because sometimes
images have multiple tags and they'll
appear as different lines in your list
but you can see that they all have the
same image ID so you know they're
aliases now look at the size this is
less than 4 megabytes in size which is
remarkable for a Linux distribution now
let's run this will clear the screen and
we'll say docker run and we want a TTY
or terminal interface and connect to the
input/output streams of the container
we're gonna give the container and name
we're gonna call it client that's the
name of the container that's running
remember the image is different the
container comes to life puts a
read/write layer on top of the image and
then allows us to continue on run a
program or whatever we need to do so
we'll say that we want to run the Alpine
image and when it comes to life
specifically we want to run the program
in SH which is the Alpine shell so let's
do that and notice how quickly it comes
to life that's one of the benefits of
these containers that comes to life in
the in order of milliseconds whereas a
virtual machine can take a minute or two
minutes to come to life and this is
Linux so let's check I can say date I
get the date back I can say present
working directory or at the root and I
can ask Who am I and it comes back and
says you're a root okay well it's CD
which takes us to the home directory of
the current user and we see that it's
slash root which is correct and now we
want to touch a file and that's going to
make an entry in the filesystem so if we
do that and say LS L we see that we have
the file it's zero bytes long because we
didn't add anything and we're we've
created state so let's exit and clear
the screen now that there is a docker PS
command that looks at the process status
and there's nothing running but if we
say docker PS - a we see that we have
our container it's named client it's
based on the image Alpine the container
has its own identifier and it was
running the bin s H command but if
stopped so we want to restart it so we
can say docker restart client now if we
say docker P us we can see that it is up
and running however we're not attached
to it so let's change that let's say
docker attached client and now we're
back connected to that container if we
CD to the root directory confirming
we're there and then we say LS - L
notice that our file is there so we have
you know rejoin that running container
and we can see that the state that we
created is still there so let's look at
a counter example let's go back up to
the command that we use to create that
container and this time create one
called client
to
and if we go to the root directory let's
confirm that's where we are and list the
directory we see nothing so let's go
outside and take a look at docker PS - a
and see what's going on we have two
containers notice the names are
different
there's client and client - and they
were created at different times run at
different times but they're running the
same program so we've got two different
sets of state based on the running of
the Alpine image okay now let's remove
these containers so we're gonna say
docker RM client and docker RM client -
and then we're going to say docker RM
client -
and now if we say docker PS - a we find
that there's nothing there
okay let's pull down another image we're
gonna say docker pull the requisite
hello world and now we can see
type that correctly we have images so we
still have the Alpine image we only
remove the containers and we now have
the hello world image so we can say
docker run hello world
and it comes back with an output message
so this is a case where there is a
default program that runs all we had to
say is run the container it pulls it
into memory activates the container it
jumps to the default running program and
then displays this output and if you
let's clear the screen and look at the
images again notice how small these are
it's a it's a handcrafted image that
only requires one point eight kilobytes
truly tiny okay so now let's clean up
after us what we want to do is run the
docker RM command to remove containers
and what we're going to do is use docker
PS - a queue as a command to return all
the identifiers of the containers and
there is one that was the HelloWorld
container so what we're going to do is
we're gonna say docker remove and we're
gonna look we're gonna spawn a child
process and that's going to run the
docker PS - aq it'll return those
numbers and then we're going to remove
all of them so there it is and there is
equivalent command for images you say
are MI and we're going to say docker
images - q for just their identifier and
that will remove all of the images so if
we clear the screen say docker images we
see that there's nothing on our computer
Hey
want to become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing click here